>> Laura:>> DIRECT CASH PAYMENTS
AVAILABLE TO AMERICAN CITIZENS
EARNING LESS THAN $99,000 PER
YEAR.
EXPANDED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS,
THE AVERAGE WORKER WHO HAS LOST
HIS OR HER JOB WILL RECEIVE 100%
OF THEIR SALARY FOR UP TO FOUR
FULL MONTHS.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT, BY THE
WAY, WE HAVE PLENTY MORE TO GO,
BUT THEY ARE THINGS THAT NOBODY
HAS EVER HAD AND ATE A PACKAGE
LIKE THIS.
>> Laura: IT IS A BIG AMOUNT
OF MONEY, A LOT OF MONEY.
THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP EARLIER
TODAY TOUTING THE AID PACKAGE
THAT PASSED THE SENATE LAST
NIGHT 96-0.
THE HOUSE IS EXPECTED TO PASS
THE STIMULUS BILL TOMORROW, WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN A SURPRISING TWIST,
NANCY PELOSI IS TAKING CREDIT
FOR IT ALL.
>> WE DID JIU-JITSU ON THIS, IT
WENT FROM OUR CORPORATE FIRST
PROPOSAL TO A WORKERS FIRST,
DEMOCRATIC WORKERS FIRST
LEGISLATION.
>> JOINING ME NOW, HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY.
CONGRESSMAN, WAS NANCY PELOSI’S
80TH BIRTHDAY TODAY.
DID SHE GIVE HERSELF A LITTLE
GIFT THERE?
IS THAT WHAT HAPPENED TO MAKE
THIS $2 TRILLION BILL BETTER?
>> I KNOW IT IS HER BIRTHDAY,
BUT IT DOES NOT GIVE HER THE
RIGHT TO LIVE.
99% OF THIS BILL WAS ALREADY
DECIDED ON SUNDAY, SHE HELD THE
BILL UP.
LOOK WHAT WE JUST FOUND OUT
TODAY, ALMOST 3.3 MILLION
AMERICANS JUST LOST THEIR JOB
LAST WEEK.
WHILE SHE WAS HOLDING A SPILL
UP, WHY?
SHE WANTED TO CHANGE ELECTION
LAW, SHE WANTED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD TO BE FUNDED, SHE
WANTED THE GREEN NEW DEAL, SHE
WANTED MORE MONEY FOR THINGS
MONEY FOR THINGS WEARY CITIES.
THAT IS WHAT SHE WAS REQUESTING,
THAT IS WHAT WAS KEPT OUT OF IT.
THIS BILL IS JUST ABOUT WHERE IT
WAS, SHE DID GET $24 MILLION
MORE FOR THE KENNEDY CENTER,
THAT IS HER JIU-JITSU.
THAT IS THE ONLY THING THEY’RE
ABLE TO DO.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES,
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR THOSE WHO
NEED IT BY THE INCOME LEVEL, WE
PROVIDE MONEY FOR HOSPITALS THAT
ARE IN CRISIS RIGHT NOW, BUT
THEN WE TAKE THE SMALL BUSINESS
WHERE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
WORK, AND WE PROVIDE FUNDING, WE
GIVE THEM ALONE.
THE BIG PART OF IT, IF YOU PAY
YOUR RENT AND YOU KEEP PEOPLE
EMPLOYED, THAT IS A GRANT FROM
GOVERNMENT.
WE ARE TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE
EMPLOYED IN THIS NATION.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, I AM
HEARING FROM A LOT OF BUSINESS
OWNERS.
PEOPLE WHO HAD TO FURLOUGH 900,
700 PEOPLE IN THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE HEARTBROKEN.
WHAT THEIR CONCERN IS IS THAT WE
NEED A DATE CERTAIN.
BLOOMBERG HAD A BIG PIECE ON
THIS TONIGHT.
THE DATE CERTAIN IS REALLY THE
THING THAT IS MOST NEEDED.
TO INJECT A SENSE OF THERE WAS
ANOTHER SIDE TO THIS, WE WILL
GET ON THE OTHER SIDE AND IT IS
NOT GOING TO BE A MONTH, IT IS A
DATE CERTAIN.
IF WE DON’T HAVE THAT, THEN
$2 TRILLION AS A DROP IN THE
BUCKET.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> THIS PRESIDENT IS LOOKING AND
TALKING TO EXPERTS, BUT ALSO
REALIZES AND TELLS THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WE WILL COME BACK AND
BUSINESS WILL COME BACK, THERE
MAY BE SPOTS OF AMERICA THAT
COULD OPEN UP SOON AND OTHERS
WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS.
THAT IS WHY THIS BILL PROVIDES
MORE THAN TWO MONTHS TO PAY FOR
YOUR EMPLOYEES, TO NOT LAY THEM
OFF AND KEEP THEM EMPLOYED.
IF YOU ARE A LARGE EMPLOYER, IT
HELPS YOU SECURE THAT LOAN BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY GIVES YOU A TAX
CREDIT WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS PLAYING FOR YOUR
EMPLOYEES, ABOUT 50% OF IT FOR
THE NEXT TWO MONTHS.
THAT DATE CERTAIN IS WHERE THIS
PRESIDENT IS WORKING TO TO GET
AMERICA WORKING AGAIN.
THIS BILL ALLOWS YOU TO STAY
EMPLOYED WHILE THAT TIME GOES
FORWARD.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
EMPLOYEES WHO LOSE THEIR
HEALTH CARE?
IF THEY’RE GOING TO BE MORE
MONEY FOR OBAMACARE, MEDICARE?
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
>> IT’S MOST IMPORTANT FOR THEM
NOT TO LOSE THEIR JOB, IF YOU
HAVE FEWER THAN 500 EMPLOYEES,
WE ARE GOING TO PROVIDE YOU THE
MONEY, NOT A LOAN, BUT A GRANT
TO PAY YOUR RENT AND PAY YOUR
EMPLOYEES.
YOU KEEP 100% OF THEM, WE PAY
100% OF THAT SALARY.
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS THAT WE GET THROUGH THIS,
JUST AS YOU TALK ABOUT DATE
CERTAIN.
WE WILL GET THROUGH THIS, BUT WE
WILL KEEP YOU EMPLOYEE SO YOU
WILL NOT WORRY ABOUT HEALTH
INSURANCE.
>> Laura: THE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE STRUGGLING ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE MORE THAN 500, BUT LESS THAN
THE BEHEMOTH TECH COMPANIES.
CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS SOMETHING
SAID TODAY BY L.A. MAYOR
MAYOR GARCETTI WHO IS BRACING
FOR THE INCREASE IN CORONAVIRUS.
HE IS MAKING HIS OWN WARNING, TO
THE REST OF AMERICA.
WATCH.
>> FOR ANYBODY LISTENING OUT
THERE, THIS ISN’T ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS YOU SAY THAT IS
NEW YORK, WE ARE DIFFERENT.
FROM THE SMALLEST TOWN, NO
MATTER WHERE YOU ARE, THIS IS
COMING TO YOU.
EVERYBODY IS THE NEW WHEREVER
THE WORST CITY IS RIGHT NOW, IT
IS GOING TO BE IN TOPEKA,
ATLANTA, LOUISVILLE.
>> Laura: DO YOU AGREE THAT
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN L.A. AND
NEW YORK IS GOING TO ALSO COME
TO SMALLER TOWN AMERICA WAS TO
MARK MEDIUM-SIZED CITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES CUSTOMER CAR
THEY’RE ALL THE SAME WHEN IT
COMES TO COVID-19?
>> I DON’T THINK THEY ARE ALL
THE SAME, PEOPLE WASHING THEIR
HANDS MORE SAVES PEOPLE, PEOPLE
DISTANCING THEMSELVES, THE
THINGS WE HAVE LEARNED IN THE
LAST MONTH MAKE US SAFER.
WHAT IS HAPPENING ALSO ON THE
GROUND, LOOK AT THE THERAPIES
THAT ARE BEING CREATED.
LOOK AT WHAT WE ARE BEING ABLE
TO MAKE ALREADY, LOOKING AT A
TRIAL WHEN IT COMES TO A
VACCINE.
IT TOOK US TWO YEARS TO GET TO
CLINICAL TRIAL AFTER SARGE, WE
ARE ALREADY IN CLINICAL TRIAL.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
SHIFTED WHAT IS GOING ON.
LOOK AT WHAT WE ARE DOING AND
TESTING, AND THE LAST EIGHT DAYS
WE HAVE TESTED MORE THAN
SOUTH KOREA TESTED IN THE LAST
EIGHT WEEKS.
BY THE END OF THIS WEEK, WE WILL
BE TESTING 100,000 PEOPLE IN A
DAY.
>> Laura: DR. BIRX SEEMED TO
WANT TO BRING EVERYBODY SEE YOUR
LEVEL DOWN BECAUSE OF THAT
FAULTY MODELING, THAT REALLY GOT
EVERYONE SCARED ABOUT THE NUMBER
EVENTS THAT WOULD BE